it's Wednesday by the way I think I
can't help but notice that in your video
on Monday you failed to address the
pressing question of whether I can be
your Sigma jig player please so Hank a
nerdfighter made Henry a Halloween
costume you'll never guess when he's
going as Hank in news of children not
dressed as pizza Shawn from the
uncultured project is in Bangladesh
right now working with Save the Children
to help 10,000 kids in a project funded
by nerdfighteria stay tuned to his
Twitter and YouTube channel links in the
doobly-doo and since Shawn got to
Bangladesh he's received word that the
ponds and filter that nerdfighteria
funded is still up and running
nerdfighters Hank and further news of
worldsuck reduction many nerdfighters
have asked where they can get a bracelet
like mine that says this star won't go
out these bracelets on her Esther Earl
our friend and fellow nerdfighter who
died a couple months ago from cancer
there is now an answer to your question
you can go to dftba calm / Esther and
you will find bracelets for sale Hank we
bought the bracelets and allen at dftba
records has offered to process and
package every order for free which means
they're fighters that 100% of the money
you spend on these bracelets will go
directly to the this star won't go out
foundation which is a new organization
founded by Esther's family to help other
families with kids who have cancer that
this star won't go out foundation is
another way that with Esther we can work
to make the world suck less so get your
bracelet dftba.com / Esther die there's
something I'll take the other day I did
a blog TV show where we raised a lot of
money to help James at Wars cat get a
surgery and then we also raised an equal
amount of money to fight malaria by the
way if you don't know James Wars you're
missing out doobly-doo so we raised
enough money to get James and Wars cat
surgery but it turns out the surgery was
cheaper than they expected so James had
more and his wife drove from Texas to
Chicago to give me a check for the
difference and I just put the check in
my pocket because I figured it was like
10 dollars or something I'm looking for
my French - llama llama this is why
we're never gonna be a top class
youtuber no props then a couple days
later I'm preparing to do laundry and
I'm going through my pants and what do I
find but a check for 500
forty dollars and this is where I need
French the wall but I made my first a
walnut joke there it is it's better the
whole time
then a couple days later I'm going
through my pants getting ready to do the
laundry and I find the check and I open
it up and I'm like French the llama $540
show heck as much as I wish that it were
this $540 is not my money it's
nerdfighteria shmoney so I have to ask
you
nerdfighters where you want this money
to go my inclination is to donate it to
the diss star won't go out project did
you get your bracelet yet by the way get
your bracelet and then to do a matching
blogtv fundraiser for the uncultured
project and Save the Children but we can
do it the other way around or we could
do something else entirely I don't know
it's not my money it's your money so let
me know what we should do with it in
comments thank you James for negotiating
with your vet to make your cat surgery
so freakin cheap nerdfighteria thank you
for all that you do to decrease
worldsuck from your own communities all
the way to Bangladesh thank you for
being awesome Hank I will see you yeah